[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París un programa de radio
Francia internacional en colaboración
con la televisión Franz 24 en la que
como cada semana damos la palabra a
personas del mundo de la política las
ciencias las artes los deportes de la
cultura y claro está de la sociedad
civil el instituto de la visión de
Francia es un centro de investigación de
renombre mundial dedicado a enfermedades
de la vista hoy vamos a acercarnos a una
de sus actividades de la mano y las
explicaciones de Ignacio Alcalá
doctorando de neurociencias Ignacio
Bienvenido a esta escala en París Buenos
días Muchas gracias por la invitación un
placer tenerlo con nosotros la vista es
uno de los sentidos más importantes del
ser humano perderla o nacer sin ella
siempre representa un Drama así mismo
comprender cómo funciona eso es uno de
los elementos más complicados si se
puede decir de la el funcionamiento del
propio ser humano usted precisamente
trabaja en uno de esos mecanismos En una
de esas nuevas técnicas que permiten a
las personas que la vista o han nacido
sin ella tratar de recuperarla y esto se
llama Ni más ni menos que sono genética
explíquenos Qué quiere decir esa palabra
un poco extraña para el público en
general perfecto Sí nosotros o en mis
investigaciones me centro en desarrollar
una nueva técnica para desayunar
prótesis para poder establecer la visión
en gente que está sufriendo de
enfermedades como el glaucoma que corta
la comunicación entre el ojo y la parte
y el resto del sistema visual que está
en el cerebro y entonces la zona
genética la zona genética se centra en
poder activar las neuronas con otros
sonidos y para eso necesitamos
sensibilizar a neuronas con ultrasonidos
es y necesito televisión como lo hacemos
usamos
herramientas de
modificación genética para que las
neuronas que nos interesan estudiar
puedan volverse sensibles a ultrasonidos
muy bien las investigaciones que ustedes
están realizando tiene que quedar claro
para nuestro público son de carácter
experimental eso es muy importante que
se tengan en cuenta y se centra usted lo
decían Cómo dijéramos reactivar la
corteza visual cuando se ha roto el
contacto entre las neuronas del cerebro
y las neuronas del ojo esto es correcto
exactamente más que reactivar es como
tratar de encontrar una forma de
transmitir directamente lo que queremos
hacer ver al paciente directamente en el
cerebro y ya no pasando por el ojo
porque el ojo lo que hace es como
recibir toda la información visual que
tiene enfrente de sí mismo el paciente y
enviarlo en cierto código al cerebro
para que sea procesado es una cosa por
demás apasionante Pero yo imagino que
este tipo de experiencia ha nacido de
una serie de reflexiones de intercambios
a nivel internacional no es algo nuevo
que explíquenos Cómo nació esta este
tipo de de experiencia que están de
experimento que están ustedes realizando
la visión siempre fue como una cuna para
recibir a nuevas técnicas para
establecer la visión en pacientes que
son en seriedad por ejemplo Fue la cuna
de para las prótesis que usan implantes
retinianos o por ejemplo para una
técnica que se llama autogenética y
visto que la sonogenética comenzó a el
término son genética fue creado en los
años 2015 y ya en los años 2016-7 en
miratorio como destinaron una parte del
equipo para justamente desarrollar y ver
si la zona genética puede ser
potencialmente usada para establecer la
visión en pacientes ciegos Ignacio
hablar precisamente de estos términos
científicos de la ciencia pues no es
fácil no vamos a tratar de hacerlo como
si fuera una disección para que todos
nosotros podamos comprender precisamente
de Cómo va esta situación ustedes hablan
o decíamos el experimento que ustedes
están realizando tiene que ver
precisamente con las neuronas yo
preparando esta misión leía que por
ejemplo el cerebro humano cuenta con
cien mil millones de neuronas es decir
que a un número 100 le agregamos pues ni
más ni menos que nueve ceros es una
cantidad impresionante verdaderamente
cuando ustedes hablan de conectar
neuronas es alguna neurona en particular
Cómo se hace este procedimiento que sin
duda de ser bastante complicado es una
muy buena pregunta como hoy Gracias a
todas las herramientas que tenemos a la
modificación genética
nos permite justamente poder elegir en
qué parte el cerebro queremos estudiar y
también Qué tipo de neuronas queremos
estudiarlos porque claramente en el
cerebro no solamente ignorancia de otros
tipos de células pero nosotros nos
interesamos en estudiar las células las
neuronas excitatorias del cortes visual
que son justamente las que generan
la respuesta o la información que hace
procesada para darnos una perspectiva de
imagen que tenemos frente o sea que
dentro del cerebro o dentro del ojo hay
este tipo de neuronas que como usted
dice excitan reactivan dijéramos una
cierta manera de imagen visual es esto
exactamente ahora bien Ignacio hay un
segundo elemento que dentro del
experimento que ustedes están realizando
llamó mi atención un término también
bastante complicado que son los canales
Mecano sensibles Mecano yo me acordaba
de los juegos de niño cuando era uno
pequeño los mecanos Pero esto de Mecano
sensible Qué quiere decir qué quiere
decir primeramente el origen de estas
proteínas son proteínas el origen de
proteínas son la naturaleza poco a poco
a lo largo de los años desde los años 70
hemos comenzado a caracterizar y
encontrar proteínas que son mecanos Qué
quiere decir que se activan cuando
sienten un estrés mecánico en la
membrana de la célula en la cual ellos
están por ejemplo
la proteína que en la cual estoy usando
actualmente es una proteína que se
encuentra en la bacteria icoli la cual
ayuda para regular su equilibrio
osmótico Qué quiere decir que la ayuda a
adaptarse a la presión que que esté en
su exterior
Entonces los ayuda para supervivencia
entonces una vez que hemos encontrado
esa proteína poco a poco los
investigadores han hecho los han
propuesto la idea de que sería
interesante saber si con esa proteína
podemos activar las neuronas han visto y
después que hemos probado eso nos hemos
planteado el desafío de poder crear una
una terapia un instrumento para
establecer la edición que es mucho más
menos invasiva que las técnicas que
existen actualmente menos invasiva
Ignacio una pregunta en estos
experimentos ustedes trabajan con
bacterias con que con virus Cómo
trabajan ustedes porque claro cuando uno
habla de ciencias Generalmente tiende
uno a pensar que hay bacterias o virus
con los que se está trabajando realmente
no no trabajamos con materias hemos
recuperado el código genético de una
bacteria para justamente saber cuál es
el código genético de la bacteria que
nos de la proteína de esta materia que
no interesa
actualmente justamente Cuál es nuestro
nuestra herramienta de modificación
genérica que usamos son los virus son
virus inofensivos casi los mismos virus
que necesito usados para las vacunas
contra el covid y lo que es estos virus
es como entrar en las neuronas que nos
interesan estudiar dejar el código
genético de la proteína micanosensible
que nos interesa justamente estudiar
hacer que la neurona que nos interesa
puedan producir estas estas proteínas
microssensibles que se van a ir después
localizar en la membrana de la neurona y
una vez que sabemos que estas proteínas
y están en la membrana de las neuronas
que nos interesan nosotros enviamos
ultrasonidos y ya que esta proteína su
mecanos sensibles se van a activar
cuando enviamos otros sonidos y así van
a producir gente que la neurona se
active si entiendo bien es una especie
de no ver pero tener la percepción de
que se está mirando algo de que hay una
luz que está llegando es esto de lo que
está usted exactamente como el inicio de
toda de toda nueva técnica para poder
desarrollar una técnica para restablecer
la visión es justamente hacer ver a los
pacientes o en este caso que es todavía
una fase experimental a los roedores
hacer ver fosfenos son flashes luminosos
Y eso es como la prueba de que como
logramos activar las neuronas a nivel de
la corteza visual y también estamos como
induciendo una percepción visual
decíamos es una fase experimental usted
acaba de mencionar una palabra clave que
son los roedores es decir que están
haciendo experimentos con esos roedores
háblenos un poco más de este tipo de
experimentos cómo está funcionando esto
como en Nuestro objetivo es llegar hasta
la fase clínica y antes de llegar a la
fase clínica nos tenemos que asegurar
Cuáles son los mejores condiciones para
que este método funcione Cuáles son las
características los otros sonidos que
tenemos que enviar para lograr la mejor
activación posible
preguntarnos también si en qué
condiciones el animal llega a ver
bajo qué condiciones de animal pueden
lograr ver justamente lo que comentaba
los fenos y además sobre todo ver si
este nuevo método es seguro entonces
todo eso estamos evaluando para después
dar el gran paso que es justamente pasar
estado clínico pero yo creo que para eso
aún nos falta unos buenos cinco diez
años cuánto tiempo lleva este
experimento en práctica en práctica como
decía anteriormente la zona genética el
término genética se creó en 2015 y ya
desde 2016 y apareció mi instituto
Entonces te puedo decir que desde 2016
ya lo estamos trabajando ya estamos
desarrollando y evaluando
si puede llegar a ser usado con una
técnica para establecer la visión usted
decía va a llevar tiempo de que
evidentemente una vez que haya pasado la
fase experimental se pueda eventualmente
utilizar como fase clínica para un ser
humano como las personas
tienen alguna idea precisamente ustedes
hacía referencia cuánto tiempo podría
tardar esto porque la ciencia está
evolucionando muy muy rápidamente ahora
puede ser un lustro puede ser una década
Cómo evalúan esto ustedes
Yo creo que el punto más importante que
tenemos que hablar actualmente es si
este nuevo método no causa ningún daño
cerebral ese no es objetivo y gracias a
que poco a poco hay más técnicas que nos
logran Mostrar si hay cualquier daño
cerebral
lo estamos lo estamos como testeando
actualmente y yo creo que idealmente
vamos a estar seguros si este nuevo
método es seguro totalmente yo creo que
en unos cinco años idealmente vamos a
poder ya decir que podemos pasar a fase
clínica O sea que a escala de lo que son
las Innovación de las nuevas tecnologías
es un plazo verdaderamente muy muy corto
ahí lo digo idealmente no puedo decir
algo entre 5 a 10 años pero como digo
como mientras no estemos seguros de que
Esta técnica Es segura y cuáles son las
mejores condiciones para activar la
neuronas Esta técnica preferimos antes
ser cautelosos y continuar en esa fase
experimental Ignacio decíamos en un
principio seguramente ustedes están en
contacto con otros institutos con otros
centros de visión en el mundo el
instituto de la visión de Francia lo
decíamos está a la punta en la
vanguardia misma a nivel internacional
con Qué otros centros colaboran ustedes
o con Qué otros centros trabajan más o
menos este tipo de nueva tecnología
efecto como
uno de los fundadores de nuestra
televisión es también como director de
un hospital de oftalmología en Estados
Unidos entonces ahí normalmente En donde
podemos como cuando llegamos a la fase
clínica poder hacerla los estudios
clínicos en su hospital y pues qué otros
institutos tenemos institutos en
Alemania en Inglaterra sobre todo
también en Japón y en China sobre todo
japonés china son estos que están
trabajando mucho con solo genética
entonces hay mucha relación con ellos
estamos llegando al final Ignacio me
gustaría una hacer una pregunta que me
parece que es importante precisamente
este centro de la visión trabaja con
equipos
multidisciplinarios hay especialistas en
ingenieros en electrónica hay químicos
hay matemáticos es lo que se podría
llamar la criminata de la ciencia se
está elaborando ya podríamos decir
estamos en viendo ya el nacimiento de lo
que será la medicina del nuevo siglo
vamos a decirlo así más que haya la
medicina no Cielo Yo creo que podemos
decir que van a eso va a ser una nueva
forma de estimular en el cerebro del
nuevo siglo ya que como decía esta este
nuevo esta nueva forma de estimular es
la menos invasiva que creo que va a
existir en los próximos años entonces
esto habría nuevas formas de estimular
el cerebro casi donde queramos pues
llegamos ya al final de esta escala en
París Ignacio Alcalá me queda sino
agradecerle su presencia en nuestro
programa muy amable por sus
explicaciones a ustedes les damos una
nueva cita y sí aquí la próxima semana
en otra escala en París gracias por su
presencia
[Música]
[Aplausos]